my name is Rodrigo Urbandale I'm
associate professor at the TC school of
computer science and Columbus State
University in Columbus Georgia and the
name of our talk is probabilistic
cellular automata from I recall that
cluster signatures right my name is
Jorden Huffman I am an instructor at
Columbus State University in Columbus
Georgia also and this is a co I'm the co
speaker for this talk
this work goes all the way back to 2003
2004 when I started working with Steven
and we were looking the structure of the
space at the rule spaces the structures
in general has been considered to be the
distribution of the the behavior is
random you know it could be anywhere in
the space because we normally do not see
a structure in this space but at that
time I thought I think there is some
sort of a structure and I started
looking for that and without going into
too much into the details if there if
you want the details of this if you're
really interested in this there's a
twenty two page paper that I published
in complex systems last year that
explains at all so what I did at that
time you know I was looking to see if
there was a way that I could organize
the the rules and other peoples have
done that and they have not been able to
do something like that but it occurred
to me that there was a way that I could
partition and break the rules into two
different pieces so there will be and in
this case I'm talking about I'm assuming
I'm talking about two states and radius
one radius two radius three etc etc so I
partitioned out every single Road into
two pieces I call them primitive
primitive zero primitive one and each
one of those will have a description or
have an equation for each one of those
so that I could form the rule based on
those two when I did something like that
you know I created these functions that
will help me and in this case you see
here the break rule I can take any of
those rule this is the ECA the
adventurous era automata I would take
each one of those I can break them up
into primitives here you here see there
30 for instance is six and three one 10
is 10 and 7 etc so I can break them
apart and I can put them back together
you know which is something like they
couldn't do with Humpty Dumpty I think
well anyway so we have this in here we
can break all this etc and then we are
able to
- fine
what is it in in the particular
primitives that is causing change one of
the problems that we had for the
Langdon's lambda back in the eighties is
that they were counting once only and in
reality with what you see and this is
the two distal primitives
when you count once in the primitive
zero it is actually meaningful because
introducing change but when you count
once in the primitive one they are
actually staying the same because this
one and the output is 1 it remains the
same so there you actually have to count
the zeros so those are the ones that
costs change in the behavior of the of
the rule you can go from from 204 204
which is the identity no change to 51
which is complete change it was the
complement in they go from one to the
other so anyway I created this and then
I found that those primitives in this
case the ECA would have 16 primitives
and 16 primitives if I do a product you
know of those of those two sets then I
can get all 256 when I found us though
that I could not order them and that was
my mistake at the beginning I was trying
to order this in a plane and I was not
being able to to really see any
structure to see what I could find that
the that the rules class to where over
here or the class one over here I
couldn't do that I could find different
ways to order it and that's what most
people told me said if I can just change
that how I want it it's gonna be
different so this is seems arbitrary to
me so when I started looking into this
and I look at the number of ones number
of zeros and in this to p0 p1 I found
that actually is a partial order and
then I will say what to put them in
there and I said oh that looks different
so I said if I look at this in the two
dimensions but these dimensions are
partially ordered that will give me a
very strange looking space of
connectivity and this I take the entire
space and it partially order it and then
I saw what I have seen before but
not as clearly that there were pockets
of rule of class one there were other
pockets it's just class two all together
in classes class three all together and
I saw that there was some meaningful and
and and meaning in that so that's when
he got involved into this and I asked
him to create a crawler into the space
and it was flat and we were able then to
go into one rule and see all the
neighbors and we started to see all
these neighbors that were similar to
each other and later on I decided okay
let's go ahead and instead of just
looking at those let's automatically
take a one rule and find the clusters
around and that's what the work that he
did for his master's he just finished it
recently so I mean okay that's a whoo
this is kind of hot so what we point the
phrase we coined is cluster signatures
what I was able to find with my rule
crawler as I move from node to node the
way the partial ordering system has the
neighbors set up because remember each
neighbor is only one bit apart from the
central node that you're observing at
that point there was a pattern to that
so I created a clustering Alastor
algorithm that actually figures out a
signature for a rule so a serpent's each
triangle they all have the same exact
signature and no matter how many times
you run the signature you will always
get a surfaces triangle so the way the
the signature works is when your p means
it is positively effective okay
n means it is negatively effective so
for instance if your MPs of zero
primitive zero the base state is zero
okay so and a positive change to peace
of 0 means the bit has to be 1 and a
negative change means that the bit in
peace of 0 has to be 0 ok if you're in
peace of 1 the base state is 1 so that
means to change like it was saying
earlier appium in peace of
is a zero in a in an piece of one is a
one and then you have what with the
magic behind this really is the the
positions that are marked D so these are
dynamic positions inside of the bit
string okay inside the primitive bit
string so anytime there is a D it could
flip to either 0 or 1 and it will not
change the outcome the output of the
rule so when we run a cluster signature
like this
for instance on the next slide so will
we run when we create the rules for this
particular signature okay what we get
are all of these surfaces triangles okay
and every time you run in PPN dddp you
will always get those exact serpents
nice triangles every single time okay so
there are three ds3 dynamic bit
positions so that's two to the three
different rules that it could create
because the bits flip and it doesn't
matter okay so when we actually can take
the compliment of that and get all of
the opposites so when you take the
complement the bit the the piece of zero
and the piece of one switch and then
they reverse and so now the signature is
P D D D in P P N and now we see it
actually generates for us all of the
complement rules for that every so every
time you run that signature it will
always create those exact rules okay
let's keep going so then we tried mixed
in or otherwise known as non-uniform
cellular automata and what we did was we
actually had a random distribution of
the same exact rule so those of those
eight surfaces triangles we would take
every single one of those and randomly
distribute those into a column for a
rule and then we would evaluate down so
when we get to this particular cell well
this cell evaluates as if it were rule
this cell will evaluate as if it were
ruled 218 and so on and so forth and we
value it down and it creates the same
exact image as the the base rules which
we will show you in just a minute and
then that really didn't serve our
purpose as well so we actually created a
different way and that's the
probabilistic cellular automata where
what we do is we're actually using the
signature to create the rules so anytime
there is a D it is actually dynamically
probabilistically introducing change
into the rule and so we can force a rule
to learn to look a certain way and
almost in a sense rule engineering if
you will so one of the things that we
need to mean I don't know how clear this
is but before we go and do the
demonstration so we say all these things
because what we want to show you is a
demonstration project that we have ready
that we could actually show all this
probabilistic shadow automata one of the
things for this particular cluster
remember when you look at your table I
mean we can go to an KS book you can go
into any other things that you go 0 to
255 you see all the evolution of all
your rules do you know what those are
they are all over the place we never
seen you know there they give you the
same output but they are all over the
place
so how are they related this is how they
are related
our clustering in in in the way that we
put all these things together put them
together so this to me confirms that
there is coherence in how we order the
rules they are all connected in an hour
and by the way I'm working I am so glad
that they are doing doing unity link i'm
working with the hololens to create a
three dimensional view of this space so
that I can walk around and then I can
connect it with Mathematica to do
computations for me so that I can study
this because this is a very really
strange
wait yes go ahead a strange way of of
ordering the rules but anyway so that
gives us a way of really joining all
this that rules that seems to be
completely separate they're not we
actually got the heart of the sierpinski
triangle and we found the other parts
that are not important
we found the essence of that but
particular pattern so this is the mixed
or the non-uniform cellular automata so
this one is one that what you we
selected for each one of the cells we
selected one out of the eight and then
if he has it written so that he can
hover over each one of these cells and
it tells you which rule is using so go
ahead and oh yes none are we problems
you know how it is it's the Wi-Fi yeah
anyway but what what happens with this
you see what this is ninety that means
that that particular cell is evaluating
ninety and if we moves all over the
place in there it will find all those
eight that we had before it works
exactly the same for a single cell okay
so this is the make sort of non uniform
but this is still deterministic right
because you define it you have it in
there and you run it the next one which
is the one for for which you have a
demonstration this is in fact
probabilistic this one has the the
cluster signature itself and everything
is that the part that is deterministic
then add the piece and the ends that's
deterministic but these are things that
would change every time you evaluate
this rule so you can define this you can
actually use a base rule we can do this
in radius one radius two we can actually
go to Arabia from radius one to radius
two and then we can see the cluster
signature and in this case we have all
offered peace all over the place
this means this is changing this
positive change and this is actually 51
which is the complement rule whatever it
is 0 will be 1 and vice versa so we have
you know as we explore this we had some
of this yes sometime actually we have in
here bigger there we go we have one we
call the triangles with tendrils and
then we define it this is just exploring
this is what we're trying to find this
which is P P P and n D D D so that was
very interesting to me you know you have
like it the the the white is seeping
through the sides and we can actually do
the stochastic or the complement scuse
me when you do the complement it doesn't
have exactly the complement because you
have all these things that would
disappear but if we change the initial
conditions it comes back to that this
comes back to the idea of you know it's
a single cell a1 with whites always the
simple one depends you might actually
have the complement of that initial
condition okay that was one the other
one is we call that rips from top and
triangles this actually was very pretty
we saw that what this morning so P D D P
oh there you go
this one here you know it has a in fact
triangles right at the end every Sunday
finishes have a triangle very very
interesting we do that also for
complement and we have the same issue
but we change deterministic you know we
flip it around and now we have it the
other way and there you go you change
the seed every changes everything in
here another one we call this one ribs
on avail
which is stochastic we do P D D D and D
D P that's it right so we see that that
they're like you're you're tearing the
you know avail and the interesting thing
is that there are places where they
interact with each other and they
becomes completely white and we also
have the complement for that one and
another one
six your parents I mean this is your
planners you've seen this is your
planners right we see that all kinds of
box you type that in the Google Images
or their sis your parents well when we
do these kind of seashell patterns and
I'm gonna see I know that we are about
to be done with this one more one more
there you go all these four variations
are running from the same initial
conditions they are exactly the same
nonetheless when you look at each one of
the evolutions they're all different not
only they are different they're also
similar for your eyes if I ask you are
those patterns the same you will say
yeah they are the same the same way that
you will take a look at a seashell and
look at the pattern and look at another
one it said yeah they are the same but a
machine will tell you no they are not
the same because it's comparing
identically but we know that they are
the same well this is the same time off
the same and I can run this many many
times and they will always give you a
different set with the same conditions
we're not changing the C we can change
the seed in the you'll see but it still
will it will be different but
maintaining same seed
because this evaluates the rule every
single time but it still and this is the
intriguing part it follows and it gives
you the same output how does it do to
make sure that it will have the same
conditions global conditions so this is
what we call in a complex system
structurally stable you can run it over
and over and over and still gives you
exactly the same up yeah the last one
yeah this is white noise for instance
this is we decided say okay let's take a
look at this
all of them are random every single one
they are Jodie's all these so every time
the evaluators simply randomly chooses
one or the other for whatever input you
have so I started looking into this and
see let's see which is the bit that will
change it will give us something we
started going one by one most of them
were just noise until we found that if
you just flip that one it gives you
something like the roots you know roots
or plans or lightning just a single bit
now this is I know that it's just a bits
if you do the radius too if you want to
really start playing with this you have
32 bits to start you know looking for
certain things in here now if you go
into each one of this I said we just
spent traversing this we have found all
kinds of interesting things we still
don't understand what he says that we
found but what I can see is it seems to
me that I'm picking an area of the
computational universe that is used but
what we see in nature creating patterns
that look similar to humans but they are
not identical at the low level meaning
they are coherent or they are
similar globally speaking but they are
no identical when they are local this is
what we see in nature this is something
that I've been asking myself for so long
how can a seashell we'll have that exact
cellular automata and everyone who had
to have it but then everyone who had to
have different conditions but what are
the chances that you will find two
seashells with the same exact pattern
computationally speaking I wouldn't know
how to do that before I do now that
doesn't mean I understand how and that's
what we wanted to share with you if you
have any questions I don't know we can
answer them though this one yes it's
gonna be available we already turn it in
but we're working on the demonstration
for this this is not complete we're
gonna put it into the demonstrations
project so that then you can just play
with it
each its yeah this is a rule this is in
radius - yeah 32 bits yeah by the way we
have base under the ECA for you know for
8 bits because we're introducing one
more possible state we have six thousand
six thousand five hundred sixty one
rules probabilistic rules Sonos 256 but
six thousand you know some change yes
yes yes oh yes there is
we have not actually looked at too many
of them yet to actually be able to tell
you yes because some of the patterns
that we found are not as clean as the
sierpinski which one does oh yes right
right for the character I'm not sure see
we we sort of just found that I had just
enough time to send for you know to
present it here which I thought there
was a ideal place to cover presented and
have the feedback from you and the
questions that you may have but now I
need to look into that in fact when we
looked at that and we have the 3ds
everything else is actually what defines
the sierpinski triangle the rest is like
it doesn't matter if you just you know
leave those however you want
they will not affect the main
characteristic yeah it was something
that we need to look and see the
distances in this but that's why I want
to visualize this space you know which
is the partially ordered space and see
how is it that they are related in see
the shapes of those clusters in this
space Thanks any other questions
that's exactly the kinds of things that
we are going to be looking into you know
this this is like oh my god we found out
we're going to share everybody else but
I even though we don't understand yet
but those are the kinds of questions and
in fact I have an entire page of just
questions that we want you know we won't
answer but those are the kinds of things
that we're looking into yes
the reason is that I was looking for
global behavior so we were simply
comparing we can't actually change the
comparison the metric that we're using
and then compare we use even Fourier
transforms in analysis of images and
then we use bit by bit
etc but we can dust it's a plugin we can
remove that one put that one and but
then this one you can explore manually
as well and then you can decide it said
I want this and then you find the
cluster yeah all right I think that's it
if we have any other questions we'll be
glad to fill those and all that time
thank you thank you